So far, we may have encountered assertions in tests, in particular, in unit tests.
Here, assertions are being used to check the results of a single run, mainly the test run.
What we're going to look into is assertions that are integrated into the program code itself.
Where the check all runs at once.
A classic example for the use of assertions is a square root program.
In the beginning, when invoking square root, we want to make sure
that x, the parameter, is non-negative.
I'll skip the actual computation of square roots here because this is the subject of another class,
but before we return to the actual square root, we want to make sure
that the square root actually is a square root.
How do we do that--well, we square the square root
and check whether it's identical to the original argument x.
These two kinds of assertions form a pair and both of them have very specific objectives.
An assertion that's being called at the beginning of a function
and which checks the properties of the arguments is called precondition.
An assertion which checks the result of a computation
before it's actually being returned is called a postcondition.
If you have such explicit checks in your code,
this greatly increases your chances of quickly finding the bug,
because these checks would re-invoke every single time that the function is executed
and if they don't fail, you know that the computation
is actually correct, which is a good thing.
If you remember, our cause-effect chain has a succession of program states,
where a defect introduces an infection which is then propagate to become the failure,
imagine what happens if you actually do have assertions in your code
that check large parts of your state.
Now imagine what happens if you do have assertions in your code
that check large parts of your state for whether they're valid or not.
Suppose you have an assertion that checks all of these area every time a function is invoked,
then you wouldn't see the failure only at the last moment but you would see the failure
as soon as the infection spreads towards.
If you have another assertion that covers this part of the state,
then you would see the failure at the very moment it is introduced.
which of course also means that you can immediately identify
the defect that causes the infection.
The earlier you see an infection--for instance, because an assertion fails,
the shorter the cause-effect chain, we need to investigate.
Also, if you do have parts of the state that are covered by assertion
and these assertions don't fail, then we know that the state in here is actually not infected
and so in your search, you can narrow down your search towards those parts of the state,
which are not covered by passing assertions and all of this happens automatically
with every single run, every single test run, and if you want so, even every single production run.